إن كل من Google و Facebook هما الاحتكار الثنائي الذي
يجمعان مليارات الدولارات كل عام
ويقومان بذلك بالكامل تقريبًا من خلال
الإنترنت على سبيل المثال مقابل كل دولار يجنيه
Facebook من 98 سنتًا
يأتي من الأعمال ، فهذه الشركات
أفضل من أي شركة في التاريخ في
اكتشاف ذلك.  ما تريده وتعرض
لك إعلانًا عن هذا الشيء ،
تهيمن هذه الشركات تمامًا على سوق الإعلانات عبر الإنترنت في الولايات المتحدة
لدرجة أنها أنشأت احتكارًا ثنائيًا
يشبه الاحتكار باستثناء
وجود شركتين بدلاً من واحدة ،
لذا فإن الشركات التي تعتمد على عائدات الإعلانات
مثل  يكافح ناشرو الأخبار
للتنافس ضد العملاقين
وبالطبع الإعلانات الرقمية ليست النوع الوحيد
من الإعلانات ، لكن الإعلانات الرقمية تمثل أكثر
من نصف إجمالي الإنفاق الإعلاني
ومن المرجح أن تزداد حصتها بمرور
الوقت ، لذا دعنا نقول في عيد الميلاد هذا  Cake
تمثل جميع عائدات الإعلانات الرقمية التي يتم
إنفاقها عبر الإنترنت في الولايات المتحدة  2018 التي وصلت
إلى ما يقرب من مائة وعشرة مليارات
دولار الآن من هذه الكعكة ، تعد Google إلى
حد بعيد أكبر لاعب يأخذون 38٪
من الكعكة بينما يعد Facebook بعيدًا عن
الآخرين حيث يأخذون 22٪ مما يترك
لنا 40٪ متبقيًا من أجله  أي شخص آخر ، ولكن
بعد ذلك تأتي أمازون
بحصة سوقية تبلغ حوالي سبعة بالمائة وهذا
الارتفاع تأخذ Microsoft 4٪ من
الأفق بنسبة ثلاثة بالمائة تليها Twitter
Yelp و snapchat يأخذ كل منهما
نسبة واحد بالمائة بعد كل ما تبقى لديك
أقل من ربع  الكعكة التي يمكن
للجميع تقسيمها عندما أقول
الجميع أعني كل شخص
يتضمن المنشورات الوطنية التي سمعت عنها
من المنافذ الإقليمية التي ربما لم
تسمع بها من قبل والمواقع التي
لم تسمع بها من قبل عن كل هذه
الشركات تتنافس ضد كل منها  الآخرون
والعملاق التكنولوجي الكبير وهم يخسرون ،
لكن ليس فقط الوظائف التي
فقدها ، فإن العالم أسوأ حالًا بدون
الصحفيين الذين
يكشفون عن الأشياء السيئة التي يكتشفها الصحفيون  هذا هو
ما تدور حوله الحرب في فيتنام ،
فلنأخذ فقط الصحف المحلية التي
تم تدميرها في العقد الماضي
وفقًا لدراسة واحدة على مدار الخمسة
عشر عامًا الماضية ، 1300 مجتمع في الولايات المتحدة.  لم
يعد لديها صحيفة محلية
واعتبرت صحارى إخبارية ، نظرت الدراسة الأخيرة
في تلك المناطق التي فقدت
للتو صحيفة ووجدت أن
الصحف المحلية تحاسب حكوماتها على
إبقاء تكاليف الاقتراض البلدية
منخفضة وفي النهاية توفير
أموال دافعي الضرائب دون
الاحتفاظ بهذه الصحف المحلية  من خلال النظر إلى
الحكومات ، أظهرت الدراسات أن
الإنفاق الحكومي قفز مع زيادة الرهانات الحكومية
وتزايد العجز في
الإنفاق المهدر وارتفاع التكاليف
على دافعي الضرائب.